[Musique]
Véronique prince Michel seoget Jonathan
Trudeau bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir je vais
faire une petite parenthèse sur le
soccer sur le foot parce que Michel
Cécile ne restait qu'un partisan de foot
à Montréal ce serait vous
éclairer ma lanterne est-ce qu'on a
est-ce que aidez-moi à ce que je mesure
mais mes espoirs pour les prochains
jours est-ce que le Canada a un espoir
quand même réel
absolument aujourd'hui
c'est la chanson de Reggiani est
suffisait de presque rien c'est réussi
c'est le penalty dans les premières
minutes du match changer l'allure de
complètement de ce match là ils ont deux
autres équipes à rencontrer la Croatie
qui est en difficulté c'est une bonne
équipe mais qui est un peu comme la
Belgique commence à vieillir et le Maroc
qu'on a vu pas capable de faire de
résultats contre la création aujourd'hui
de finir dans la Coupe du monde pour le
Canada OK et c'est accessible si on a
gagné mais là après
2e tour après ça là on va être dans le
cours des grands ok Jonathan est-ce que
vous suivez ça Véronique ou moins ou pas
moi j'ai effectivement espoir espoir de
peut-être un jour m'intéresser au soccer
j'aime beaucoup le sport mais le soccer
j'ai beau essayer j'ai encore écouté cet
après-midi j'ai apprécié la performance
de l'équipe canadienne mais c'est un
sport qui m'échappe un peu
malheureusement
je vous comprends mais Michel Cymes je
vais t'emmener un match puis tu vas
changer d'avis puis c'est de ma faute je
suis jamais allé en fait je vais je
devrais Véronique suivez vous ça un peu
allez vous serez jouer j'ai joué au
soccer longtemps mais oui effectivement
mais j'avoue que moi je trouve que ça va
faire du bien si on peut se rassembler
autour de Simpson qu'après deux ans et
demi de pandémie là ça va avoir des
événements comme ça qui permettent de
rassembler les gens tous les horizons
etc ça je pense ça ferait du bien on
espère qu'ils vont rester là longtemps
c'est le sport le plus pratiqué au
Québec par les par les jeunes ça ça
dépasse le hockey et tout ça donc bravo
ok
un mot aussi sur un rode Lebel est-ce
que c'est de nature vous croyez
Véronique je commence avec vous à
redonner confiance pour reprendre
l'expression
aux gens aux femmes qui voudraient
porter plainte au système de justice
voilà un cas quand même éclatant clair
net et qui démontre aussi que personne
n'est au-dessus de les lois même pas un
parlementaire même pas un législateur
finalement alors c'est clair que c'est
une onde de choc au Parlement ici ça l'a
été d'abord et avant tout au moment de
son arrestation parce que comme
n'importe qui qui a dans son entourage
une personne qui a commis des agressions
il y avait le Harold Debel qu'on
connaissait au Parlement qui était pas
partisan qui était impliqué dans à peu
près tous les comités ils continuaient
même de faire son travail de député
alors que le processus judiciaire était
en cours il a même fait le transfert de
pouvoir quand la nouvelle députée est
arrivée lui a laissé des documents ils
ont même embauché certains de ses
employés à la CAQ donc il y a le Harold
de Bell qu'on a vu publiquement et là on
apprend qu'un autre à rôle Lebel en
privé finalement qu'on ne connaissait
pas et ça ça frappe vraiment tout le
monde je dirais Jonathan
moi je pense effectivement le message
est positif en ce qui concerne la
confiance envers le système de justice
le Japon dans le même sens que Véronique
donc la notion qu'il n'y a pas personne
au-dessus des lois mais j'irai même un
peu plus loin c'est-à-dire que parfois à
tort probablement est-ce que tu as
raison des fois il y a des gens qui vont
se dire bah si vous avez une certaine
notoriété si vous avez certains moyens
si vous êtes bien positionné ben il y a
peut-être moyen de j'oserais jamais dire
jusqu'à s'acheter un verdict mais de
favoriser de favoriser l'un d'aller dans
une direction plus qu'une autre je le
répète parfois à temps rassurément mais
il reste qu'il y a souvent cette
perception là lorsqu'on voit des gens
qui sont connus qui ont notoriété donc
en ce sens-là je pense que le message il
est il est positif par contre je retiens
également les délais c'est long là ça a
pris deux ans quand on pense aux
victimes il y a sûrement encore un
parcours du combattant moi j'espère à
Québec les projets pilotes de tribunaux
spécialisés qui sont en place on
arrivera éventuellement à améliorer nos
performances en la matière non au moins
il y a un message je pense qui est somme
toute positif on va en parler des délais
dans une seconde parce que l'autre sujet
c'est exactement ça Michel c'est Auger
un mot sur ce verdict aujourd'hui
personne n'est au dessus des lois je
suis d'accord avec tout ce qui a été dit
là-dessus il y a aussi le fait que la
décision c'est un jury qu'il apprend
c'est 12 personnes qui sont choisies
dans la communauté et ces gens-là ont
estimé la crédibilité de des de la
partie playante et de la partie
défendresse et c'est pas vrai que parce
que vous êtes un député parce que vous
êtes connu parce que vous êtes même
reconnu comme un très bon député parce
que c'était le cas de Monsieur Lebel que
vous allez vous en tirer c'est pas comme
ça que ça marche très bien parlons-en du
système de justice aujourd'hui je le
disais la presse qu'a publié tout un
dossier le Journal de Montréal avait
publié tout un dossier aussi à quelques
mois on le sait il y a des délais
incroyables Jonathan vient d'en parler
des victimes qui attendent des accusés
qui attendent aussi en fait tout le
monde qui attend et là on pourrait
perdre ça pourrait parce qu'avec l'arête
Jordan après un certain temps c'est
terminé ça ça s'arrête tout je veux
entendre mettre la voix qui est la
bâtonnière du Québec et la réponse du
ministre de la Justice aujourd'hui on
revient tout de suite
ça va vers un mur en criminel mais
en civil aussi il y a des délais
vraiment effrayants par exemple à
Montréal quelqu'un qui veut avoir
obtenir jugement pour les petites
créances doit attendre environ 18 mois
alors pourquoi
inonder les tribunaux du temps de jeu
j'ai pourquoi pas essayer de régler par
la médiation et pourquoi nous membres du
Barreau qui connaissons le droit ne
pourrions pas nous aussi
être davantage des membres décideurs
donc faire de l'arbitrage lorsque un
dossier qui qui demande une résolution
parce
écoutez moi je suis en mode solution moi
ce que je souhaite c'est qu'on trouve
des solutions j'ai eu j'ai fait
plusieurs démarches depuis le mois de
décembre dernier pour tenter de
convaincre la direction de la cour de
faire en sorte de suspendre sa décision
puis de trouver des voies de passage moi
je suis ouvert à donner des ressources
supplémentaires à donner des jeux
supplémentaires effectivement mais faut
que ça se traduise par un gain
d'efficacité on fera pas uniquement
ajouter des ressources pour avoir le
même résultat ou est-ce qu'il y aura pas
une minute de temps de course
supplémentaires pour les Justiciers
c'est pas acceptable c'est des fonds
publics les soins attendent déjà
longtemps les victimes quand elles ont
le courage de dénoncer leur histoire
elles veulent pouvoir tourner la page
donc lenteur système manga
d'informatique manque de personnel
ajouter à ça la juge en chef qui décède
de réorganiser le travail ils vont
siéger non pas une journée sur deux mais
non pas deux jours sur trois mais une
journée sur deux donc c'est moins la
jugeront d'eau
et le ministrehaire on a une recette
parfaite parfaite Michel ceroger pour
pour accélérer encore plus les délais on
a l'impression
effectivement un bras de fer entre le
Ministre de justice et la Juventus de la
Cour du Québec ça dure depuis très
longtemps c'est pas le premier événement
dans cette histoire là la juge peut
valoir que c'est au tribunaux de s'auto
réglementer c'est vrai mais en même
temps celui qui paye la facture c'est
mieux c'est justice alors à un moment
donné il va falloir que ces gens-là
s'entendent qu'il veuillent ou non puis
d'autre part
donner plus de ressources plus de juge
oui ça commence à presser parce que on
parle de de dixième de dizaines de
milliers de causes qui pourraient être
rejeté pour des raisons de délais la
redjordon
c'est pas acceptable dans une société et
effectivement les je pense pas qu'on
puisse dire que les juges au Québec sont
paresseux qui sont exprès pour prendre
des journées de congés ou pour
que les procès de se déroulent pas
rapidement mais
un moment donné ce qui a un tel
backlog comme on dit en anglais
tient-elle des attentes parce que passer
de juge là il va falloir régler ça et
dire
de la productivité là dans ce passage
mais Jonathan c'est que la juge en chef
dit moi il faut qu'il siège moins parce
que c'est plus complexe moi donc ça me
prend au moins 42 juges de plus
maintenant le problème c'est qu'il
s'entendent pas puis en fait on a
l'impression que le bras de fer est trop
public est-ce que le ministre quelle
avenue il a devant lui pour régler la
question finalement
ça semble très difficile mais moi je
vais vous dire une chose avant d'aller
plus loin j'ai vraiment une pensée pour
les gens qui nous écoutent qui sont
nombreux il y a des gens à la maison on
parle de dizaines de milliers de
dossiers qui sont à risque mais c'est
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
des victimes potentielles qui déjà
trouve que les délais sont extrêmement
longs et là qui se disent est-ce que je
vais faire les frais d'un conflit de
personnalité que j'aurais attendu tout
ce temps-là pour rien je trouve que
c'est absolument inhumain ce qui se
passe en ce moment maintenant quand
j'écoute Simon Jolin barrette je sais
souvent on dit ouais il est un peu froid
ne déteste pas une bonne confrontation
pas nécessairement celui qui est le plus
ouvert à la négociation mais le
totalement raison lorsqu'il dit la juge
me demande 41 juge supplémentaire ok
mais c'est 41 juge là n'accélérait en
rien le traitement des dossiers actuels
ce serait uniquement pour pallier au
retard créé par le nouveau mode de
fonctionnement ce qui était absolument
inconcevable moi j'en reviens pas que
quelques années plus tard on en soit
venu à tolérer si on veut les impacts de
la rageworlden c'était un électrochoc
pour éviter les délais indus parce que
les accusés aussi ont des droits là
c'est rendu que non seulement au
tolèrent ça mais qu'on a une juge en
chef qui dit bah vous savez finalement
peut-être qu'il y aura des délais
supplémentaires mais il faut ce qu'il
faut qu'on doit le faire maintenant
c'est absolument inacceptable donc vous
dites le ministre raison Jonathan de
tenir son bout là-dessus
mais il y a sûrement une solution
mitoyenne moi je veux bien qu'on
reconnaisse que la réalité a changé pour
les juges que le traitement des causes
est différente ils ont besoin de
davantage de temps quoi qu'on ne lui
également dans la presse que il y a
entre autres un juge qui a claqué la
porte en disant ça n'a aucun sens mes
collègues à l'Ontario eux travaillent
4,5 jours pour une journée de
délibération nous on veut faire du 1
pour 1 moi je veux bien comprendre qu'il
y a peut-être une voix de passage à
trouver mais quel était l'urgence de
mettre en place une décision unilatérale
effective rapidement comme ça sans être
capable de voir comment on peut le faire
de façon progressive c'est là où je
trouve que l'espèce de conflit de
personnalité mène à une situation
totalement inconsolable mais justement
Véronique va falloir le conflit de
personnalité se règle parce que c'est
les citoyens comme dit Jonathan qui pèle
l'addition là je peux certainement que
ça va se régler je suis pas certaine du
tout même parce qu'il date depuis
longtemps sinon je les barrette mais
juste d'arriver en poste en 2018 et déjà
au début de l'année en 99 par exemple
sur la question de la laïcité on se
rappelle qu'à ce moment-là on parlait de
la laïcité de l'État déjà la juge
Rondeau était sortie en entrevue pour
dire ben vous savez est-ce qu'on a
vraiment besoin de limiter un droit
fondamental de porter les signes
religieux les jeux j'en porte même pas
et déjà à ce moment-là ça avait irrité
si mon jeune barrette cette sortie-là
puis après ça il y en a une autre en
lien avec la loi 86 il y en a une autre
en lien avec les tribunaux spécialisés
et donc tout ça ça s'est accumulé au fil
des années et là ce qu'on me dit dans
les officines c'est que la juge Rondeau
elle est en poste jusqu'au mois
d'octobre prochain après ça soit qu'elle
devient juge pluie demeure juge sans
être chef de tribunal ou alors elle
prend sa retraite et j'ai l'impression
que pendant la prochaine année en fait
ce bras de fer là va se poursuivre parce
que vous avez deux personnes qui ont des
visions complètement différentes madame
Rondeau veut avoir plus de ressources
plate pour la qualité justement du
système de justice Simon gelain barrette
de son côté dit oui la qualité oui les
ressources mais il une vision plus de
réforme de réorganisation du système
finalement pour qu'il devienne plus
performants et si François Legault a vu
depuis 2019 il y avait un conflit entre
ces deux-là et qu'il a décidé de garder
simonjolin barrette en poste comme
ministre de la justice c'est que si mon
jeune barrette à toute sa confiance
finalement
le Premier ministre en gardant le même
ministre c'est savait qu'elle avoir ce
conflit là qu'elle est perdurer
[Musique]
dans les bons papiers du Premier
ministre au point même où vous savez
normalement
quelqu'un qui doit être un peu plus en
retraite parce que il est un peu le
premier magistrat du Québec
c'est plus politique du gouvernement
alors ça fait l'affaire de Monsieur Lego
de toute évidence alors mais il va
falloir un moment donné mettre aussi
plus de ressources au niveau judiciaire
que ce soit une journée sur trois
journées sur deux ou une journée il
manque de juge et ça fait des délais
épouvantables pour les contribuables
pour ceux qui l'auront à se présenter de
votre tribunal c'est clair ça
un petit mot sur l'ingérence chinoise on
revient avec ça ça roule en boucle les
gens sans perdre leur latin là Monsieur
Trudeau je vais le faire écouter
écoutez ça puis demandez-vous en
écoutant ça mais de quoi a-t-il je
reviens avec ça je suis obsédé de quoi
a-t-il parlé avec le président chinois
donc si ce qu'il dit aujourd'hui ça a
toujours été ça on écoute
quand il y a des allégations qui sont
sortis dans les médias j'ai demandé à
nos services de renseignement de
regarder au fond des choses je me fais
briefer régulièrement sur les enjeux qui
pourraient préoccuper nos institutions
l'intégrité de nos élections et j'ai
reçu aucune information là-dessus donc
on doit se poser des questions sur sur
est-ce que on est en train de protéger
bien nos élections est-ce qu'ils ont été
comprise je comprends qu'il y a eu des
rapports médias là-dessus mais moi ce
que j'entends de nos services de
renseignement de ceux qui sont chargés
directement avec toute l'information de
l'intégrité de nos élections c'est
qu'ils sont soulignés qui a aucun
problème
il n'y a aucun problème dit Monsieur
Trudeau Jonathan global avait sorti
qu'il avait été briefé il le nid là par
les services de renseignement concernant
des coches chinois en 2019 pas la
dernière fois là ils écoutaient là elles
sont pas compromis et il accuse les
conservateurs au passage de d'essayer de
faire croire qu'on est comme aux
États-Unis et que des puissances
étrangères qui viennent faire dérailler
le processus il dit c'est pas le cas
où vous en êtes Jonathan
j'écoutais monsieur Trudeau parler je me
disais le président chinois pouvait bien
dire ajouter un Trudeau c'est pas du
tout ce que vous m'aviez dit à raconter
parce que s'il était aussi vaseux dans
ces commentaires au président chinois
versus les rapports qui avaient été fait
ou l'avait été ferme qu'il avait dit au
président chinois que c'était pas
acceptable de voir redonner gérance dans
par exemple les processus démocratiques
alors que le finalement c'est pas trop
peut-être que oui peut-être que non
ils n'ont rien entendu mais il s'en
inquiète quand même c'est c'est tout
sauf est-ce que je n'aime pas c'est de
devoir monsieur Trudeau passer à
l'attaque et dire au conservateur ben là
dans le fond vous voulez faire comme de
l'autre côté la frontière vous voulez
jouer les les tactiques que Trump Bienne
et dire que peut-être que les résultats
l'élection ont été ont été faussés hors
je comprends que les conservateurs ont
une partie politique là-dedans mais moi
ce n'est pas ce que j'ai entendu ils
veulent savoir qu'est-ce que vous saviez
et est-ce qu'on sait qui était à cause
disons pas dit écoutez les élections ont
été volées ou quoi que ce soit mais
j'étais Trudeau lui dans le fond il dit
ah qui était vous pas il y a pas eu
d'impact sur sur l'élection donc pas
nécessairement moyen d'en faire
davantage j'avais l'image de quelqu'un
qui dit ben on doit tenté de forcer ma
serrure chez moi mais ils ont pas réussi
à entrer donc j'ai pas besoin
d'installer un système d'alarme
finalement non non si eux des tentatives
d'ingérence même si loin elles ont pas
été couronnées de succès on doit s'en
inquiéter et on doit être clair et ferme
Véronique
en fait quand on essaie de suivre cette
histoire on s'aperçoit que beaucoup de
contradictions parce qu'il y a un
rapport qui aurait été déposé en janvier
par le sars selon ce que global nous dit
après ça Justin Trudeau dit que lui en a
jamais entendu parler que jamais été
formé mais le quand même interpellé si
j'ai une ping là-dessus alors il y a des
contradictions et clairement au niveau
de la transparence là il y a un enjeu
mais en même temps à quel point le
gouvernement peut être transparent s'il
y a des informations confidentielles
alors tout ça fait en sorte que les gens
la maison qui a cette suivent ça se pose
énormément de questions est-ce qu'il y
en a vraiment eu les gens si oui à quel
niveau et comment on peut empêcher ça
aussi la prochaine fois et ce qui est
dommage c'est qu'en attendant ça apporte
de l'eau au moulin justement de gens qui
peuvent être confortés dans leur
position comme quoi il peut y avoir de
l'ingérence dans notre politique Michel
s'est conclusion
je ne comprends pas c'est que Monsieur
Trudeau en a parlé avec le président de
la Chine ça a été rapporté dans une
conversation la conversation a été
rapportée aux médias puis ça voudrait
dire que le premier ministre parler de
rapport média ou Drago 40 ans qui a pas
été briefé là-dessus ça n'a pas de sens
il y a quelque chose qui marche pas la
douleur marche pas
si le premier ministre ça parle au
président de la Chine c'est parce qu'il
doit avoir des renseignements s'il y a
pas une périphérique là-dessus ben il
parle de Rago quelque chose qui marche
pas d'ailleurs j'essaie de revenir à la
source de
avec Louis Blouin sur exactement ce
qu'on avait dit que le que le premier
ministre avait dit au président chinois
mais bon on va ça va être pour une autre
fois merci beaucoup à vous trois bonne
soirée au revoir bonne soirée
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI